I'm creating a website with all the
ammunition that a cyberbully will need
to attack I'm not just feeding the
trolls I'm rolling out an
all-you-can-eat buffet after uploading
some of my childhood pictures along with
my email and phone number
I offered $50 as bait and posted my
challenge to read it in 4chan ground
zero for the Internet's most vicious
trolls see what happens within hours the
hate came flying in at first it was
insults about my intelligence a few
about my age slash looks some made no
sense at all
then came the threats basically dude
people will attack your family to get to
you it's best if you don't make a public
statement that you're impenetrable I
carried on with the rest of my day as
the attacks kept coming the next morning
I discovered my Instagram and Twitter
accounts were hacked after an eagle-eyed
troll noticed my password in my
challenged photo a password my assistant
Jasmine assured me was out of focus
then the memes hit
[Music]
the cyber bullies were obsessed with one
of my photos trying to one-up each other
by portraying me as a sex dildo but one
troll rose above the rest slamming me
with non-stop images memes and
unfortunately poetry I responded to the
troll and said if he wanted my $50 he
would have to appear on camera he agreed
but only if he could choose the location
he's giving me coordinates and we're
almost there he had complete home court
advantage and I was unsure what support
we were even playing follow the light
Chuck can't even spell rights area
serious I now had a rare chance to
confront a troll face-to-face
hey man hey how should I address you
little Jesse little Jesse no do this
for lulz LulzSec lulz hacker group
yeah so I said cyber bullying me
and here are some of the things you did
they said picture of someone holding a
bottle of pills it says John Doerr zlib
tard agenda on the pills yeah
so you think I'm liberal and retarded
yeah here's another one you posted what
looks like a tweet coming from Kim Jong
Un's personal account it says got my
first intercontinental ballistic missile
working where should I send my first
nuke and then you have a pole John's
front door yeah 68% yeah I'm gonna take
issue with this I live in the United
States now if you were to nuclear front
door you'd also already be nuking United
States America is it going to happen
yeah 68% of people do want it to hit
poses all fake
you didn't actually put out a bowl No
oh so then you got into some poetry if I
made so this what you wrote
what's true of you is your mediocre but
you cover it up like a choker but you're
still a choker notice you just rhymed
choker with choker because I use the
double hats and airball how old are you
how old do you think I am like 49 all
right let's just move on what advice
would you give to kids are being trolled
or bullied online keep your sanity by
going insane I mean I was a little kid
getting bullied and toughened up okay
let's say you're trolling made me freak
out and blow my head off in a microwave
or something I don't hold personal
responsibility for your choices do you
think you'll be a troll forever or yeah
hell yeah
if anyone's gonna save the world from a
big brother-type reality it's gonna be
the trolls have you ever
felt remorseful about any of the
trolling you've done I mean you know not
at all 0% have you ever heard of
Aristotle's extreme of means totally I
have but for the viewers explain to them
so in order to correct a virtue you try
to practice the extreme antithesis of
that virtue because you don't find
virtue on one extreme or the other
virtue virtue miss isn't binary it's
balanced yeah that's Aristotle's extreme
of me yeah exactly
well you did win the cyberbully
challenge that hands down so I do owe
you 50 but actually will you give me an
apology first before I give it to you
no like for the horrible things you
said online you can get a handshake and
maybe a bro hug all right $50 handshake
no no
[Music]
you